bonjour à tous viol du nouveau chez
apple l'iphone 10 devrait disparaître
cette année
cet été
[Musique]
l'iphone 17 annoncés il ya pas très
longtemps et les sorties sur le marché
fin 2017 et pourtant à l'été 2010 8
pourrait disparaître
alors quel est le problème avec cet
iphone 10 il ya des choses qui vont pas
des choses qui vont pas pas chez nous
plutôt du côté de la chine et qui
forcerait apple a changé un petit peu
ses plans par rapport à ça il faut nice
alors je vais vous expliquer qu'est ce
qui se passe réellement par rapport à
l'iphone 10
et qu'est ce qui va arriver après parce
que si l'iphone 10 disparaît c'est un
vrai problème parce que du point de vue
de tim cook l'iphone dix c'était le
smartphone qui devait montrer la voie
pour les dix années à venir donc si même
pas un an après son lancement il
disparaît quelle va être la voix et où
est ce qu'on va aller c'est aussi un
problème parce que beaucoup de personnes
qui l'ont acheté alors pas forcément
effectivement en chine mais en europe et
beaucoup aux états unis donc si cet
iphone 10 disparaît que va-t-on
retrouver la place
donc on va regarder ça ensemble en fait
un petit peu un point global et voir un
peu ce qui cloche
l'information n'est pas officielle elle
n'a pas été donné par apple mais par
l'analyste le plus respecté d'apple
mines chico qui travaille pour cacher
sécurities et micro c'est vraiment pas
la personne qui se trompe en règle
générale quand ils donnent des
prédictions
on est dans le vrai parce qu'il a
vraiment un réseau et des connaissances
qui lui permettent d'avoir les
informations les plus fiables
directement la source
alors sa prédiction est très clair à
l'été 2010 8 apple va arrêter de
produire les iphone 10 alors même que
les nouveaux smartphones ne serez pas
encore annoncés sont annoncées au mois
de septembre donc pas sorti donc pas de
remplacement direct
alors qu'est ce qui va se passer
pourquoi arrêter la fabrication des
iphones disent même pas un an après leur
lancement
tout simplement à cause d'un désintérêt
pour ses iphone sur le marché chinois
les ventes en chine serait décevante
serait pas du tout à la hauteur de ce
qui est attendu
apple ne communique pas sur ses
objectifs donc bien évidemment on n'a
pas de chiffres officiels par contre
celles au meeting qu est vraiment bien
positionné lui il a affaire directement
aux sous traitants d'apple et qui
annonce qu effectivement on est loin des
objectifs annoncés par apple
les commandes serait vraiment plus
basses que prévu initialement il se base
sur moins
18 millions d'exemplaires d'iphone 10
vendus au premier trimestre 2010 8 alors
18 millions ça me paraît déjà énorme
et par rapport à un tel marché au niveau
international c'est pas énorme
alors pourquoi un tel échec déjà un prix
beaucoup trop élevé 1000 $ ça fait quand
même cher pour un smartphone
le manque de tranchant de l'iphone 10
par rapport à la concurrence
c'est un produit qui a pas énormément
d'innovation à un prix aussi élevé
on trouve des très bons produits à la
concurrence avec des technologies tout
aussi bonne pour beaucoup moins cher
puis surtout le marché chinois ça a
marché qui adeptes de très grands écrans
l'encoche au niveau de la caméra trou
d'aix en porte pas forcément l'unanimité
d'autant plus que je comme je vous le
disais la concurrence est énorme sur des
très grands écrans et même des marques
qu'on n'a pas en france ils sont bien
positionnés sur le marché chinois en
plus à des problèmes sur le marché
chinois ce qui a des applications qui
sont pas du tout adaptés au format de
l'iphone disent tous ces problèmes
réunis font que l'iphone dit sans
contact du tout le succès sur le marché
chinois et on sait que le marché chinois
ça marche et qui est énorme
donc des lobes vous planter là dessus
c'est un petit peu compliqué en plus de
ça le cycle de remplacement des
smartphones serait prolongée de dix mois
par rapport à ce qu il y avait les
années précédentes ce qui fait que le
consommateur renouvelle son smartphone
plus régulièrement aujourd'hui notre
petit peu plus c'est qu'on a calme un
petit peu la faire donc forcément il ya
moins de vente alors ça c'est d'une
manière générale pour l'ensemble des
acteurs sur le marché des smartphones
donc forcément les ventes sont moins
bonnes
alors qu'est-ce qu'il va y avoir à la
place on imagine que si elle peut
effectivement se plante sur son produit
phare samson flactif ils vont forcément
devoir trouver des solutions
alors rassurez vous c'est la fin de l'
iphone 10 tel qu'on le connaît sur le
modèle de 2010 est par contre en 2018 il
va y avoir trois nouveaux iphone dif
dislike en tout cas qui vont arriver un
iphone 10 avec un écran oled de 5,8
pouces qui sera exactement la même
dimension que celui qu'on trouve
actuellement un autre iphone 10 avec un
écran de 6,5 pouces toujours en haut
elle qui sera une sorte d'iphone 10 plus
et un iphone 10 au format 6,1 pouces
avec un écran lcd pourquoi lcd a tout
simplement pour avoir un prix beaucoup
plus bas et un produit d'entrée de gamme
je dirais dans ce nouveau dit
des iphone ces trois nouveaux
smartphones auront bien évidemment le
design de l'iphone 10 tel qu'on le
connaît actuellement
l'ajout des modèles 6,5 pouces et 6,1
pouces en lcd permettrait d'avoir un bon
compromis pour le marché chinois
alors du coup qu'est ce qu'on va trouver
au catalogue d'apple l'année prochaine
vous est calculé à peu près les prix
qu'on devrait avoir
très clairement déjà l'iphone 10 tel
qu'il est présenté aujourd'hui va
disparaître on ne le retrouvera plus
apple pourrait très bien justifier ce en
disant que c'était un produit
anniversaire qui a forcément une durée
de vie un peu courte mais en réalité
c'est pas exactement ça donc on va
retrouver l'année prochaine on devrait
retrouver l'année prochaine reste au
conditionnel un iphone 10 5,8 pouces
oled au tarif de 1199 euros
un iphone 10 6,5 pouces oled donc un
iphone 10 plus au tarif de 1320 euros un
iphone 10 6,1 pouces lcd au tarif
oscillant entre 779 à 899 euros
retrouvera également l'iphone 8 à 6 159
euros
l'iphone 8 plus à 809 euros un iphone 7
à 539 euros un iphone c'est plus à 689
euros et un iphone est ce à 419 euros
donc bon on va quand même continuer à
avoir un catalogue très large l'iphone 6
aces va disparaître du catalogue
l'iphone et se va rester parce que c'est
toujours un format qui séduit énormément
avec ses petits formats d'écrans et
surtout un tarif abordable pour avoir
pour avoir un produit de chez apple et
avoir un os
le problème aujourd'hui de ces produits
chez apple c'est qu'ils sont extrêmement
chères forcément il faut passer à la
caisse pour avoir un produit apple sauf
si on veut effectivement les anciens
modèles mais on voit très bien que de
toute façon par rapport à la concurrence
vous avez des très grands écrans sont
pas très cher vous allez chez white plus
avec le one + 5 t vous allez même sur
les eaux nord honore view 10 chez
samsung avec le galaxy s uite le galaxy
s 9
vous voyez que vous avez des grands
écrans on va toujours
le grand écran et on n'est pas obligé
dépenser des fortunes donc pourquoi
devrait-on dépenser une fortune pour
avoir un apple pour avoir un os
c'est un petit peu là que le bât blesse
on va très bien que la concurrence elle
plus d'arrières même s'il est encore du
lcd il ya du oled de plus en plus sur le
marché avec des grands écrans avec des
produits d'une extrême grande qualité
donc le positionnement d'apple avec des
produits très chers sur le très haut de
gamme
ça commence un petit peut être
contre-productif pour eux d'ailleurs on
peut se demander ça c'est une question
que je me pose est ce que apple est pas
un peu en train de se tirer une balle
dans le pied avec un positionnement
tarifaire aussi élevé des smartphones a
plus mille euros ça commence à être
compliquée chez samsung par exemple sur
le produit le plus cher vous avez le
galaxy note 8 qui effectivement un
produit à plus de 1000 euros mais si
vous comparez par rapport aux 1,8 et os
9 cd produits qui sont quand même
beaucoup moins cher la vraie question à
se poser pour apple aujourd'hui c'est
depuis le décès de steve jobs est ce
qu'ils ont toujours quelqu'un avec une
vision claire de l'avenir
est-ce qu'ils ont un visionnaire abord
quelqu'un qui a vraiment une vision à
360 et une vision sur l'avenir de ce que
doit être la téléphonie mobile de ce que
va être la téléphonie mobile et en quoi
est ce qu'apple continuait à être
innovant pour garder un positionnement
toujours très haut de gamme
ça c'est un peu la question à se poser
dites moi vous ce que vous en pensez à
ce que vous pensez que apple est en
train complètement se planter des rails
et par rapport à ces produits par
rapport à sa gamme de tarifs
est ce que au contraire vous pensez
qu'ils sont toujours visionnaire qui
sont toujours leaders sur ce marché
innovant dites moi ce que vous en pensez
parce que très clairement autant apple a
été leader sur le marché pendant des
années autant aujourd'hui sont toujours
au coude à coude avec samsung et dans
dix ans est ce que apple risque pas de
décliner dites moi ce que vous en pensez
marc qui m'a tout sans commentaire parce
que c'est vrai que c'est hyper
intéressant pour va se rencontrent pas
ce qu'on voit qu'il ya un vrai tournant
qui est en train de se faire au niveau
des smartphones la première décennie des
smartphones est terminée on arrive
maintenant sur autre chose on voit qu'il
ya d'autres enjeux
on voit qu'il ya des écrans pliables qui
vont arriver moitié de nouvelles techno
qui vont arriver
est ce que au final apple serait pas
entrain loupé le coche est en train de
se planter
mark et moi tout ça comme d'habitude je
vous invite bien évidemment à messei des
jolies pouce pour faire plaisir à vous
abonner parce qu'on a toujours parlé
beaucoup plus beaucoup mieux de high
tech beaucoup d'infos il ya beaucoup de
surprises
vous dit pas tout tout de suite mais je
vous en réserve énormément abonnez-vous
on reste connectés
soyez sage je vous embrasse n'oubliez
pas vous êtes les meilleurs et on se
retrouve très très très très bientôt
ciao
[Musique]